joining us also tonight live from
Washington senator Ted Cruz great state
of Texas senator good to have you on the
program welcome back here's my take
senator and I think it's fairly simple
you don't get to shoot American drones
out of the sky you don't get to take oil
tankers hostage to impact and disrupt
the oil supply the lifeblood of the
world's economy
you don't get to kill Americans like
they did at the end of December you
don't get to attack our embassy to kill
Americans at our interest abroad you
don't get to be the number one state
sponsor of terror you don't fight proxy
wars you don't try to get to take over
the entire region and threaten to wipe
Israel off the map and act the way
they're acting without expecting a
response I don't want a war I don't
think you do either senator but there
has to be a response doesn't there no
Sean I think that's exactly right it ran
is exceptionally dangerous and if you
look at silh Amani taking sulemani out
he was the most dangerous terrorist in
the world the Department of Defense has
told us that he was directly responsible
for the deaths of at least 603 US
servicemen and women he has directed
terror groups across the globe including
Hamas including Hezbollah targeting
Americans targeting civilians and taking
him out has made America safer now as we
look at this missile attack tonight we
see the ayatollah khomeini striking back
and targeting america to target
targeting our bases but but but I will
say this yeah I think what what you you
cautioned in your opening monologue is
exactly right which it which is that
that we are not going to get into an
extended land war in the Middle East
we're not going to do it and and and
when you see when you see Democrats and
the media lighting their hair on fire
and saying we're headed to World War 3
this is hysteria driven by the fact that
they hate Donald Trump because it used
to be the case that we could all come
together and say that when there's a
terrorist who's targeting Americans in
this case Soleimani had just directed an
attack on the US Embassy in recent days
that taking out a terrorist targeting
targeting Americans is a good thing I
commend President Trump for following
principles of peace through strength but
at the same time
we're not going to be sending our sons
and daughters into harm's way for an
extended extended land battle in the
Middle East
senator Amen to everything you just said
and you know one of the things we should
be thankful for living in the greatest
country God above ever gave man in this
country the United States of America is
our brave military and our sophisticated
weaponry now one of the things that we
can confirm we know is that the Iranian
economy has been impacted greatly by not
bribing the mullet whoever thought of
the idea of bribing mullahs and bribing
Kim Jong Il would work I don't know
where that mindset comes from it's not
one I understand completely but the
question is this they have three major
four fineries in or in Iran senator
three I would imagine those refineries
blew up one day they got themselves a
hell of a domestic problem because
that's going to result in major poverty
for the people of Iran and if they want
regime change that's up to them maybe we
can help them with arms and help them
you know in some ways but we're not
sending our sons and daughters there
well and if you look at Iran policy I
think you've seen a dramatic shift under
Barack Obama as you noted the policy was
appeasement the policy under the
disastrous Iranian nuclear deal under
Obama was to give over a hundred billion
dollars to Iran they literally flew 1.7
billion dollars in cash in unmarked
bills on pallets and the dead of night
into Iran in a very real sense the
missiles that we saw fired on US
servicemen and women tonight were paid
for by the billions that the Obama
administration flooded the Ayatollah
with and and and if history teaches
anything it's don't give billions of
dollars to people who hate you and want
to kill you then so let me say the last
three years I've spent a lot of time
with President Trump urging him to pull
out of Obama's disastrous Iran deal he
did that he took on his own State
Department his own Defense Department
and made the right decision they're
urging urging the president and the oil
wavers you know we had waivers in place
that was allowing Iran to sell a million
barrels a day of oil the president
agreed
ended those waivers and so the effects
of these sanctions and the economic
pressure it's having a real effect but
we need to stand up to the ayatollah
khomeini is a radical religious zealot
he hates America
literally chants death to America he
calls Israel the little Satan and
America the Great Satan the way to deal
with threats like that is not through
weakness but rather strength and I think
we saw that in taking out soleimani this
past week do you believe as I do because
you're right I kind of used keep saying
over and over again you want to wipe a
country off the map and that would be
Israel and then there's a little Satan
where the big Satan all true
do you believe that that ideology that
you are rightly describing ever got a
hold of nuclear weapons do you have any
doubt because I don't that they would
marry the the ideology with the weapons
and the world could face a holocaust of
monumental proportions we did lose over
all his million cells in the last
century sir look I think you're exactly
right and it's why I've said for many
years that the biggest national security
threat facing America is the threat of a
nuclear Iran that the Ayatollah Khomeini
if he gets nuclear weapons the risks are
unacceptably high that he would use them
that we would find that out through a
mushroom cloud over Tel Aviv or New York
or Los Angeles I'm not willing to roll
those dice a theocratic lunatic should
not be allowed to acquire nuclear
weapons we stopped funding it we stopped
the deal flooding them with billions but
but we need to be absolutely unequivocal
that he will not get nuclear weapons you
know tonight could have played out very
differently if they didn't just have
ballistic missiles but they had nuclear
warheads you could be seeing literally
millions of American casualties
particularly if they put him on an ICBM
and took them to a u.s. city that's not
a risk we should allow but fortunately
you noted this we have air power we have
the ability to project force we have
economic sanctions there are all sorts
of steps short of sending in the Marines
and our mission should not be sometimes
Republicans have gotten off track and
have thought that our mission
be to turn foreign countries into
democratic utopia's I don't want to turn
Iran into Switzerland i I think it would
be a wonderful thing for the Iranian
people if they overthrew the Ayatollah
and if they tyranny and oppression but
it's not the job of our soldiers to go
in and risk their lives to do that it is
the job of our soldiers to keep America
safe and killing terrorists is a very
good way to start
senator Cruz great commentary as always
appreciate you being with us on this
busy breaking news night